Speaker 1: Another major defeat for the anti
woke clowns.
This time it is that drag ban ruled unconstitutional.
This is the beautiful detail, folks, by a
Trump appointed judge.
The Tennessee anti drag bill violates free
speech and expression.
It's too broad and too vague.
The Associated Press has a great report on
this.
Tennessee's first in the nation law designed
to place strict limits on drag shows is unconstitutional.
A federal judge says the law is both, quote,
unconstitutionally vague and substantially
overbroad and encourages discriminatory enforcement.
According to the ruling late Friday by U.S.
District Judge Thomas Parker, appointed by
failed former President Donald Trump.
Quote, There is no question that obscenity
is not protected by the First Amendment.
But there's a difference between material
that is obscene in the vernacular and material
that is obscene under the law.
Simply put, no majority of the Supreme Court
has held that sexually explicit but not obscene
speech receives less protection than political,
artistic or scientific scientific speech,
said the judge.
The article also says the law would have banned
adult cabaret performances from public property
or anywhere minors might be present.
Performers who broke the law risked being
charged with a misdemeanor or a felony for
a repeat offense.
This is a bonkers law.
It deserved to be taken down.
And so far that is the decision.
Now, will it be appealed?
We will see.
But we knew.
You know, it's funny.
It's important to let legal scholars and jurists
weigh in on these things.
But we could all see that the use of the word
obscenity was being used, not as it is required
to be used under the law, but just colloquially.
Oh, that's obscene.
I don't know.
I see a picture of a drag performer that's
obscene.
And that's my opinion.
That's not legally obscene.
And that's actually what matters here.
And good for the Trump appointed judge for
pointing that out.
The bill is vague.
It's broad.
It doesn't really define what is an adult
cabaret performance, what is a male impersonator.
It leaves room for arbitrary enforcement,
discriminatory enforcement.
But the most important thing is, listen, the
first obstacle is let's get a legal opinion
that shows the nuts and bolts of this Tennessee
anti-drug bill are ridiculous.
That's step one.
Step two.
Let's remember that it is again being pushed
by hypocrites.
Tennessee Governor Bill Lee, who previously
dressed in drag, now says this is a danger
to our children and this is the law we need.
So they are hypocrites.
Legally problematic, hypocritical.
But the zoom out the 30,000 foot.
Is that this one bill is just a part of the
larger wave of the anti LGBT legislation that
we're seeing in many right wing states.
It's targeting trans youth.
It's banning gender affirming care.
It's limiting access to bathrooms.
It's doing all sorts of different things.
And it's all motivated by the right saying
now it is trans people who are the scapegoats.
For a long time it was gay men, maybe for
like a week it was lesbians.
They never really were too worked up about
lesbians.
For a while it was gay men.
And now they're shifting over to saying the
problem is trans people.
And it's motivated by fear, it's motivated
by misinformation.
It depends on stereotypes and myths about.
Remember that first it was the stereotype
in myth of the gay man as the pedophile.
Didn't make any sense.
But gay men are interested in other gay men
who have gone through puberty.
We're not talking about pedophilia now.
They're applying that to transpeople.
People are going to say, oh, I put on a wig
and now I'm a woman so I can hit on little
girls in a bathroom that's already illegal.
It doesn't matter which bathroom you're in
already against the law.
Don't need any new laws to prevent that.
And it also essentially never happens.
And they're now targeting drag shows, too,
completely benign.
We interviewed a drag performer few weeks
ago who was very articulately able to explain
the absurdity of all of this.
So the hope here is that if this decision
is appealed, it will be upheld, not that the
bill will be upheld, that the unconstitutionality
of banning drag shows will be upheld.
And this is, again, another one of these issues
where the right now is saying, look at all
of these leftists wanting to die on the hill
of drag shows.
We're not the ones who started this thing.
We're just saying the law should be enforced
and the bills should be the laws should be
evaluated for their constitutionality.
It is because of the right making this an
issue that this is an issue left wingers weren't
going around saying, let's go around creating
a defenses for drag shows.
And for as long as the right keeps pushing
these nonsense laws.
My hope is that the left and sane thinking
jurists are going to do what needs to be done
to point out that the laws are not only hypocritical,
capricious and unnecessary, but also unconstitutional
in the way that this one is.
Let's take a very quick break.
Make sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
YouTube.com, slash the David Pacman show.
We are powering towards 1.75 million YouTube
subscribers, which will put us within that
final 250,000 subscriber push to 2 million.
Be a part of it.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
We really are now, as you will shortly see,
in the midst of the 2024 election, the Republican
primary is rapidly getting completely out
of control and cartoonish and humiliating
fashion.
And that's why you can use the coupon code.
24 starts now.
When you sign up for a membership at join
Pacman dot com.
You'll get a sizable discount and it will
be a beautiful day when you sign up on our
Web site.
We are primarily supported by members.
In all seriousness, you know, The Daily Wire's
arguing over $50 million contracts.
They've got millionaire donors.
It's bonkers what's going on.
The left doesn't have that.
And if you checked out the recent NBC News
article written about the David Pakman show,
one of the topics is the left doesn't have
that sort of donation infrastructure from
rich mostly dudes, right?
I mean, let's be frank from from these rich
white dudes that pour money into the daily
wire.
We don't have that.
And so we depend on folks who sign up at Join
Pack Mint.com.
I hope you'll do that.
You can read about the great member benefits
on our Web site.